before this video begins surprise
package time its origin unboxing time
introducing the evil 16s gaming laptop
from origin of course look at this baby
you can kiss it if you want do I need to
say more
look how thin and light this is for your
scrubs you bought a gaming laptop you
know you're hugging around like a bunch
of bricks in your bag
this baby is light and it's thin and
it's aesthetically pleasing 6 inch
display
15 inch body come on down the narrow
bezel display gives you more screen
space as well doesn't mean mrs. meme
template waiting to happen
go crazy means there's more screen space
equals more room for gaming more room
for gaming's means more gamer girl time
this evil 16s is customized with HD UV
printing as you can see very nice to the
touch you can get your own design done
as well you can even customize the
individual lights on the red/green/blue
keyboard for custom lighting I'm told
it's called lighting and not lightning
what the Frick is happening guys the
touch oh that's nice the touch pad is
glass space similar to like that of a
smartphone but Felix what's inside it's
all about the inside well here let me
tell you I have no idea what this means
but I know it sounds good GeForce r-tx
2080 max cube design it basically means
you can play battlefield 5 the GPU and
CPU in the Evo 16s will help you record
gameplay anywhere you're on
check out Origen pcs website they have a
bunch of other laptop
well from light and thin to big and
strong desktop replacements one lucky
winner as always is gonna get one of
these Evo 16s details are in Louisville
oh I thank you let's go on with the
video
[Music]
hello mina-san it's me Felix Kjellberg
it's time for me to Google myself this
should be good
I've been doing this as a series on this
channel every two years I Google myself
see what kind of changes are what kind
of development what's good what's it
gonna be you know people always comment
on my channel that I came up with this
challenge
okay now that article 13 has passed I'm
pretty sure that I can copy strikes
everyone during the Google challenge
because I came up with the first
actually it was my idea and I completely
stole it from her but regardless of that
mics I can't copy strike me she she's
not a youtuber anymore
googling myself 18-plus
probably googling myself my net worth in
the title next one lies she knows and
that's really what ever wants to know I
Google myself challenge a markiplier I
Google myself you know even wired what
what do they do they call it
autocomplete just because they have
can't have Google in the title but let's
get real here it's the same goddamn
story look at markiplier is in there I'm
only acting like this because I'm salted
that I will never I will never happen
[Music]
you know the only good thing coming out
of these autocompletes is this clip is
that like a personal attack my favorite
favorite two seconds is this a good
reference it's a good mean all right
let's start a incognito tab because I
need to Google myself and I need fresh I
need the freshness okay done
we Google myself now what are we
immediately know from this information
that's right everyone I'm 180 centimeter
the perfect height there will never be a
better height than 180 people keep
saying oh he's so insecure about his
height oh yeah well then why does Google
say I'm 180 apparently I made a graphic
novel in 2017 I wasn't aware of this but
that's always good to know you know you
can learn a lot about yourself so it
says that I am known as PewDiePie a
Swedish youtuber comedian and video game
player I'm a video game player not a
gamer I'm a video game player thank you
very much
best known for his video to video
content which is mainly consisted of
let's play commentaries I suppose my
library Quan in the quantity speaking
and that is not wrong people also search
for markup I Logan claimed this
knowledge panel what does that mean can
i oh oh like for your best what so I can
change my height oh hell yes it's
happening boys hibernate oh it's review
time reality can be whatever I want
I'm 181 okay why he mentions in his
latest Google myself vide
we're just happening right I'm sourcing
ass I go hasn't changed yet what
goddammit so I like these because they
had they summarize basically the main
questions people have about me which is
number
one how much do does pewdiepie make a
day by Forbes estimate he receives 12
million in 2015 according to the mana
nation
this helps increase his net worth to 68
million the very old data isn't it gets
also made nearly 42 million in
merchandise what no way
I wish Jesus Christ by the March guys
I'm not made anywhere near that amount
three thousand four hundred dollars per
hour not bad for a university drop by I
don't know exactly how much I make per
day it doesn't seem too far off which is
pretty crazy when you think about it
money is such a I go right in the deep
end but money is such an interesting
topic for me because I obviously didn't
start YouTube to make money a sad thing
I've learned is how much people value
money in a way or at least the idea of
money people look at money as something
undoubtedly good it couldn't possibly be
something negative to have money which
is understandably a strange concept for
people to accept but you look at people
that win the lottery and having money
then fundamentally changes their their
whole life you know not just how they
view life but also how other people view
them and I think that's a change in
particular that I feel like I really
want to protect and that's the reason
why in a in a way I try to live modestly
because obviously I don't but in
considering how much I make I try to
delay modesty because I don't want to I
want to just live a normal life I don't
want it the money to change my life it's
great to have but if it it can also
obviously become a problem
millionaire ranks about why money's bad
okay I think it's important to note
those I know I think a lot of people
think oh if I only had money then it
would solve all this problem for me when
it's not really true and also the
concept of when is it ever enough unless
you have a goal of how much you want to
make if you've invested in the stock
market then having money is obviously a
stressful element as well because once
you have money you're afraid of losing
money there's a lot of things to
consider
that I think isn't brought up enough and
I think a lot of people look at money in
a way that oh they only had money all my
problems will be solved which I can say
it's not true okay everyone is a blood
sucking vampire and they want your money
and as soon as they know you have money
they aren't coming for it okay that's my
little rant of the day here my goal is
to save up a little bit so I can buy a
house in Japan and have enough to be
able to sustain myself for the future
I'm gonna live a long life and I want to
be able to have it for a while as well
you know that if anyone is wondering why
you know maybe why does he still do
brand deals and all this stuff that's
why I have that's my goal and I think
it's important to have a goal in mind
what is Peter Pisan Network okay this
one says 20 million okay I would say
it's definitely more than that
what is PewDiePie famous for for lets
playing I guess that makes sense
I don't think people now associate me
with Let's Plays but that is what made
me become the beg you to ba it's pretty
crazy how much this channel has changed
over the years from screechie let's play
commentary too I just spit out a rice to
screechy meme commentary everyone that's
right now I'm really I'm really proud of
myself for making these decisions that
at the time seemed really stupid but
obviously it paid off a really really
big time I think a lot of youtuber fell
in the trap that they always have to
please their audience no matter what and
that should be their main goal and and
that's the kind of youtubers that end up
becoming sort of slaves to themselves
and their own content and eventually it
just leads to the demise of the channel
because after a while people aren't
gonna be interested anymore if you're a
minecraft channel and you always just do
minecraft videos obviously you can find
a lot of success in that don't get me
wrong after a while people are gonna get
tired of it although minecraft is a
terrible example it's closed clearly
it's still very popular fortnight for
example you know that has a
owning people aren't gonna be always
looking for for tonight content I don't
know what I'm getting at the point was
for me when I did horror videos
it was getting exhausting every single
day I played horror games going ah ah
and after a while it just wasn't funny
it wasn't interesting and it wasn't
scary anymore so I kept making horror
videos even though I didn't like it and
then people got angry at me from not
getting scared and for not enjoying it
which is like what I wasn't getting out
of it anyway so then I stopped doing it
and then people got angry why aren't you
playing horror games anymore and I
realize I'm not gonna be able to please
end everyone so I might as well do what
I enjoy and I think that was my point
that's what really paid off who is the
richest youtuber I'm pretty sure I am
NOT the richest youtuber I I don't do
these sort of mega deals I don't I'm not
the big corporate yeah I would assume do
perfect probably makes a lot more money
than me just based on the fact that they
do these massive deals
that's just pure speculation but I can
see that I can also see Ryan's toy
review making a lot more than me because
kids advertisement I don't know if they
advertise but it wouldn't surprise me if
they made more than me again just pure
speculation I have no idea but at the
same time that's what these sites do as
well they don't know how much we make so
it's always kind of annoying when people
accept these as face value they're like
oh my god he makes this much money
that's crazy oh my god superwoman made
this much that's crazy that they don't
know they're just coming up with numbers
and a lot of times these are less
confirmed by management's that do the
deals for these people so they conflate
the numbers as a way to get more money
from brand deals as a way to justify
getting paid more format brand deals oh
this person makes this much from brand
deals is PewDiePie still dating Mars yet
hey Marsha are we still dating she says
yes which youtuber has the most
subscribers ah
ah don't Google that one next Google
please what nationality's idubbbz
why is that in here he's American -
ninjas use samurai swords I don't know
why does this come in there's people I
have a brother know how to always Joe G
if I told her that Jyoti please all
right let's say I move on with a Google
myself and do some Google autocomplete
so I can go PT pi age 29 [ __ ] networth
I like the money [ __ ]
- per simulator what - per simulators
becoming relevant okay how about this is
PewDiePie moving to Japan
I wish okay it's a little complicated
getting a visa and all that stuff
apparently I spoke to a tax expert and
they said it's actually a little
complicated now because of Logan Pole
because people associate youtuber
youtuber isn't recognized as a job in
Japan or a lot of countries and then
they mentioned that thanks to Logan Paul
it's actually a little bit more
complicated thanks Logan thanks a lot
it's PD PI Swedish yes yes I am Swedish
as you can tell
let me take you guys to my own time
alright hometown I really wanted to do
this so I grew up in Gothenburg I have
not been back here and so long where are
we now okay yeah yeah there we go the
main square hey this is fun I have not
seen the thing is my two closest friends
my family and my sister moved to
Stockholm when I was living in Italy for
a short period so there's hasn't been a
moment for me to come back to Gothenburg
even though it's technically my hometown
I want to go to where where I used to
live off M Mun this is the tram I would
always take home from school
it means nothing to anyone but me
basically ah that's funny
I was literally about to say it's very
rare to get like good weather in
Gothenburg and they're actually super
look it's super sunny here and then you
can move forward and it's like this is
what is actually like in Gothenburg it's
like nope it's still sunny now okay this
is what is actually like in Stockholm
Gothenburg wherever I'm from no one
knows okay this is where I used to live
this street very central here it is this
is my street I don't know it's just too
invasive like no one knows I know live
here anymore so this is the building and
we would live on the top and hey man so
many funny stories but I don't know what
I want to share I used to always if I
was bored at night I would always throw
snowballs and people walking I was so
drunk one time when I came home that I
threw up outside the window and for sure
you know there's obviously a lot of
parking here but my parents out of all
cars that could be parked underneath my
parents car what's the one that took the
fall so my parents enter the car though
my parents are leaving this morning look
at the car then looking up see that it's
literally my window and they're like
okay well he did it that son of a [ __ ]
but they were obviouly not mad about it
I think they realized that normally they
I remember they said it they were like
usually you're not bad so you're okay
very nice parents I have this I realize
this video just became something
completely different but this is what I
want to do okay let's go to where I
actually grew up though because I only
lived my teenage years in this centre
this is a road that I grew up there's a
house super cute road then my best
friend would live in this house so we
were literally neighbors oh this is not
a privacy problem yeah that's the house
I grew up in Oh they build out the
balcony super nice neighborhood I'm very
thankful for my parents for letting we
grew up in such a great place so weird
to look back at these things oh my god
they cut down the tree there was this
ginormous
apple pear tree here and my parents
would literally always make me clean up
all the pears okay I take back
everything nice I said about my parents
okay they would always make me clean up
the pears and there were so many goddamn
pears they were so big so many pears
there was apple trees over here and I
have to clean that up too
I need to cut the grass on this hail how
do you even do that and then we were
responsible for the snow on this
staircase is there anyone Falls and dies
that would be our fault so they would
always send me out to scoop the snow how
could they how could they treat me like
this this takes me back man all right
enough with that let's go back to why
we're here
it's PD pie no no I'm not vegan
I guess I'm pescetarian basically I just
eat fish and no other meats so she is
too good to give up one of the reasons
why was when we shot scared pretty pie
season two I had to interact with a
bunch of pigs and they were so cute it's
like I don't want to eat these my my
moral is that I would I eat what I would
kill I don't like the idea of making
this uncomfortable act of killing
something so easy it's PewDiePie
American no still dating my it's P PI
Russian it's pretty PI good what a great
question no no I'm not
why is pewdiepie chairs so expensive
[Laughter]
it's a high-quality chair with Italian
leather and fashion why is pewdiepie so
hot when is PD PI birthday getting
married secret but this year can
PewDiePie speak Japanese yeah yes
no I'm true very slowly very very slowly
like trying to learn 10pt pi sing with
auto-tune yes speak Russian
no but my parents taught me a little bit
of Russian when I was growing up so I
know how to read the letters more or
less and I I mean I know a few words
mean years with Felix
yeah Roberta you a youtube when I was
young people thought Russia was gonna be
the new big country and it obviously
became China instead so they thought oh
it'd be good for him to learn Russian
thanks for nothing Russia you'd really
did it can pee deep I sue the median it
depends I get this question a lot like
why don't you just sue the media bla bla
bla bla bla I think the thing is that
you have to prove that what they wrote
they actually wrote knowing that it was
false or something like that which is
kind of hard to prove I think maybe if I
look into it there could be some case
somewhere but I really just care about
making videos right now right now use
media I might change my mind so you
better behave which will bring me to the
final tangent that I have been going on
on this video which is PewDiePie versus
the media I thought about it recently
and it's like there's a completely
different version of me existing in the
eyes of of people that read these
articles about me and as opposed to the
people that actually watch my videos and
I think it's always because people that
watch my channel know who I am and
and I think you have a pretty good
understanding of what my values are and
that I'm not this horrible person that I
am have portrayed as in the media
obviously a lot of it is self-inflicted
like yes I have done a lot of these
mistakes but I think if you if you
constantly reinforce the negative only
the negative things that someone has
done you're gonna create an ugly picture
of a person I think no matter who you
are if you constantly list all the
shortcomings of any person that person
will be it look like a really bad person
then there is never a balance or very
rarely at least a balance story about me
about the good that this channel has
done and all the positive things it's
always just the negative things listed
and I think that's why for
people I exist is like a completely
different character it's interesting I
think I will kind of give enough like I
don't really care about what people that
don't watch me think about me knowing
that other people still know the truth
in a way and I find comfort in that then
I don't feel like I need to go in some
sort of Oh guys I'm actually a really
good person look look how much money we
donated to charity I'm so great look at
all these videos and success it's so
great now I'm not about that even though
I literally just brought it up thank you
guys for watching this Google PD pie
video
20:19 Edition see you guys in two years
it's much like if this was enjoyable
sorry for all the tangents and I see you
guys tomorrow bye bye what cheaper
simulators becoming relevant no no don't
leave
no please sponsor Eagle please do
something yes this game is still
relevant
dear me
[Music]